there's a few paths to
massive wealth in life you know when it
comes to career paths so if you're one
of the younger guys watching this i want
you to listen up if you're an older guy
and you've got kids pay attention
because you can explain to them as well
number one uh what do we got one two
three four five
actually there's six
i talked about five the other day but
there's actually six
uh number one is c suite jobs ceo cto
cfo
chief financial officer chief executive
officer chief whatever officer okay
uh you need to have experience you need
to work your way up the ranks there's
very few of those jobs
but if you can get one of them very very
very few there's there's fewer of those
jobs
than there are many other opportunities
you know for being honest i'm about to
talk about on this list but if you can
get there it can be a well-paid thing
and if you're good at it um you'll be on
demand like you can move from company to
company and you know if you've done
something to fix one organization you
can move over to fix another
organization whether it's running the
business whether it's
um you know dealing with the financials
of the business but c suite jobs can pay
you very well
well into seven figures you know in fact
in some cases eight figures you know
depending on the size of the business
that you're running
um a professional licensed professional
surgeon doctor lawyer you go to school
for a number of years you get a piece of
paper that you frame in mahogany and
stick on your wall
you have the right to earn a very high
rate in some countries it's more than
others like in canada they don't pay
doctors very well here
you can be a
world-class
surgeon here in canada and probably make
twice the money
in the united states you know for
example so
but
but a licensed professional that went to
school with a specific
designation
professional designation can make decent
income like even uh
even a lawyer here that's uh working
in-house can easily make into six
figures you know a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year
um
next one would be stem science
technology engineering and maths i've
had a number of uh consults with um
guys in tech companies like tech leads
of like facebook google
um
amazon's
also if i talk to an apple guy
um
android developers i've talked to a lot
of guys in the tech world and you know
whenever i get into my consults you know
the private consults you know we always
talk about income
and some of these guys will be making
750 000 a year
um just doing geeky [ __ ] for you know
these tech companies um so that's
another avenue to make some you know
extreme wealth but keep in mind when
you're working in tech companies you're
going to be required to comply with the
current thing you know you're going to
have to hang a flag on your car and put
pronouns in your bio and all that sort
of stuff
and some people don't like that
next one would be fame
which i'm not a huge fan of
um some people like you know the
attention and the fame but um you're an
actor you're a
musician you're even an influencer
you guys saw what happened to andrew
tate a few weeks ago
and he's been reduced to one platform
now
but if you say the wrong thing is a
famous person or do the wrong thing in
the public eye
they hold you accountable the
interesting thing is you don't have that
same problem
as an entrepreneur
i know a lot of entrepreneurs that make
as much if not more money than famous
people
and you wouldn't even know them like if
you saw them you would not even know
them i was telling the story earlier
this week i had a buddy of mine that
popped over because i had to uh
guarantee his uh passport for him old
old friend i've known him for close to
40 years now
we're just catching up what he'd been up
to and he's running this business right
now
he's always been an entrepreneur for
years
he's running this business right now
where he's doing about a million bucks a
day in sales receipts but you wouldn't
know it if you saw him but there's
famous people out there that got famous
just from showing their tits and ass on
instagram or you know by
holding out to the public um on social
media platforms that they're
uh famous men
and uh making less money than him on a
daily basis
uh but there you go um so fame's another
one so we've got c-suite jobs licensed
professionals
um stem type of careers in tech fame
the next one is uh sales and then
there's one more after that
um sales would be high in sales though
luxury real estate um you sell a house
for
uh there's a listing right now that i
looked at
uh
the other day this nice neighborhood 15
mil times .025
your commission would be 375 000
on a 50 million piece of uh property
which is
a lot more common than you think
especially in the greater toronto area
um these guys usually have a team
it doesn't matter if it's high on real
estate i mean if you're selling anything
expensive you're getting a commission
for it so if you're going to sell
anything if you're good at sales don't
do [ __ ] sales jobs don't sell
you know kias or something like that um
or you know limit yourself to a job
where you're only going to make you know
high
five or six or low six figures something
like that
the
ability to sell is something that's
transferable in any field the only
difference between the guy that's
selling private jets and the guy that's
selling kias is the guy that's selling
private jets
has a nicer suit it's going to be custom
tailored he has a look he has a style to
him um and he and he believes that he
has the capacity to sell private jets to
people that are high income
folks
so
yeah if you're gonna get into sales
don't sell [ __ ] things because the
skill is transferable doesn't matter if
it's a low ticket item or a high ticket
item you might as well use your skills
to go to a higher ticket item
and the last last one and not least
which is of course you know the reason
for this cast today is entrepreneurship
the problem with entrepreneurship though
is that
it's very risky you guys have probably
heard that the vast majority of
businesses fail right like nine times
out of ten within three to five years
you're out of business
the interesting stat that they never
really talk about is
the ones that survive
out of out of the nine that fail the one
you know that survives the 10 of the
businesses that survive
97 percent of the ones that survive are
making less than a million dollars a
year in annual sales receipts which is a
[ __ ] business to be in so
you've basically
either been canned or you quit your job
and you go and start up your own thing
you get through the three to five year
uh
you know like a period of time of
[ __ ] basically where most businesses
collapse on themselves and then you're
continuing to run your business but 97
of entrepreneurs that continue to run
their business are not really making
serious money they're not making more
than a million dollars a year in sales
receipts they're making less
they generally have
a
pretty significant overhead and at the
end of the day most of them are
basically in a position where they went
and created a business to employ
themselves
which is a really bad idea
you go and do something like that you're
now exposed to all kinds of risk
uh the employee can't be sued by
something they do in a business
generally speaking the employer the key
holder you know is what they're
generally called in the business world
the key holder is the one that can get
sued they can still pierce a corporate
shield a corporate shield is a nice
thing to have it offers a certain level
of protection there's other things that
you can do which i of course talk about
in my course as well too
but
they can hold the key holder liable to
any kind of damages that they might
either experience in real life or they
manufacture a lot of the times you know
especially in the u.s
there's a
business model out there
of litigation
because it can be profitable to like you
know chase lawsuits here and there you
know over certain things and generally
speaking they're mostly manufactured if
we're being honest but
why would you expose yourself to that
risk when you could just be an employee
and punch the clock and never get sued
never have to work on weekends
um you know never have to deal with all
the headaches that come with being an
entrepreneur
the the um
like the sexy guys out there like the
elon musks of the world and the jeff
bezos of the world and that sort of
stuff like those sexy type of
entrepreneurs are very very rare right
like i said about 97 percent of business
owners make less than a million dollars
a year
and then there's those very very small
three percent that are making more than
a million dollars a year in sales
receipts that can grow into a billion
dollar business uh billion dollar
businesses are very rare elon musk is
very rare it's it's
highly unlikely
on a balance of probabilities that um
you can repeat that level of success
there's a lot of components that come
into play with skills and luck and
timing and all that sort of stuff but
the point that i'm making is that the
vast majority of businesses never crack
crack a million dollars unless
you understand the components of an elf
business
so let me explain that to you
you guys can throw questions in the chat
if you want just super chat them and
they'll pop and i'll keep an eye over
there and throw them out and i am going
to drop the link for you guys
to come in and ask some questions
i mean like look you guys have trusted
me for years to unplug you on
relationships and red pill you on that
today i'm going to red pill on
entrepreneurship and business so pay
very close attention here
so there's this podcast that i used to
listen to
2007 to 9 which i'll be honest you know
partially you know
contributed to the hyper growth that i
experienced in my debt business at the
time
because one of the biggest problems that
i had to solve was marketing you know
getting the customers on board because
when people have debt they're very
comfortable with that it's like
the amount of people that are very
comfortable with being in a physically
unfit body is unbelievable to me to the
same degree there's a lot of people that
are
physically sorry uh financially unfit
the biggest difference between
financially unfit and physically unfit
is you have to deal with that problem
every time you get out of the shower and
look in the mirror you have to deal with
a problem when you climb up the stairs
and you're winded at the top of the
stairs because your knees hurt and
you're carrying too much body fat you
know that you have a problem it's very
difficult for you to ignore when you
have a debt problem it's almost
invisible unless you have to take out
your card and pay for something and it
doesn't work or you get in a fight with
your
wife or whatever over money problems
but for the most part it's generally
invisible to most people throughout the
day so for me marketing the debt
business was probably the hardest part
of what i had to do
so i started to tune into things that
could help me you know solve those
problems and there's one
there's one podcast that i found called
the i love marketing podcast
and this guy joe polish ran it and he
had an interesting story
he was a dead bro carpet cleaner wasn't
making any money had to figure out
marketing you know and then one thing
led to another
you know a number of years later and he
became very successful and rather
podcast with this guy
and he created this notion of if you're
going to run a business there's two
kinds of businesses that you can run elf
easy lucrative and fun
half hard annoying lame and frustrating
so hat tip to joe thank you for
explaining that to me back in the day
when i needed it
what i've done with this mindset course
and by the way guys the course is pinned
in the top comment of the live chat it's
also in the description enrollment
closes at midnight tonight i don't know
when i'm going to open it up again i
don't know what the cost will be the
cost will probably go up because i keep
adding more and new material to it so if
you're interested today's the day to get
into it because again enrollment closes
at midnight
so
everything in this course is a mindset
shift just like you have to shift your
mindset when it comes to dealing with
women and relationships and what they
respond to i am going to shift your
mindset when it comes to
entrepreneurship the go-to for most
people
i'm going to go and start up this
business for that business and it's a
half business it's something with a lot
of employees a lot of overhead uh
thinner margins big risk exposure and
i'm going to explain a lot of these
points in a minute
where you don't make a lot of money
you're working long hours and there's a
lot of [ __ ] like
i've said before that things like amazon
fba you know for example fulfilled by
amazon and i have a 45 minute uh webinar
lecture on my course with my friend
bobby who ran an amazon fba business and
he explains exactly why physical
products and amazon fba is [ __ ]
but there are people that will make some
money on it they're very very rare
though right i had a guy message me
earlier this week because i was talking
about this before he goes you know
here's a screenshot i made um let me see
if i can find it actually i made um you
know i get way too many dm's don't be
able to find it he goes i made a million
dollars over three days on sales and
here's a chart and i said awesome good
for you make sure you tell people the
amount of [ __ ] that you had to put
up with
to make that happen and he's like yeah
you're right it's a very difficult
business the thing with a lot of these
businesses that you hear about like
amazon fba moving physical products
putting something on shopify some random
trinket that you get off alibaba you
source you know you put in a fulfillment
center and you ship it out is they the
vast majority of them fail and a lot of
them don't even make money there's lots
of videos that you can find right now
online of people trying to run amazon
fba or courses that they've bought
that explain to them how to make money
off of a physical product on amazon or
shopify or something like that and they
go through the entire thing and then
they reveal their experience and they're
like i didn't make any money or i lost
money right
the vast majority of them don't work out
and on top of that
when you guys see that zoom webinar
that's on my course lectures with bobby
you're going to see exactly why it fails
and amazon's a very very difficult
platform you're basically jeff bezos
[ __ ]
if
something on that
doesn't work out for them then you're
going to pay the consequences
there's another guy that i know that
that publishes a lot of books so he's
got i'm not going to give away the
details because um he wanted to keep it
private but he's got this niche so let's
call it
i don't know basket weaving
he's got this basket weaving niche and
he's got thousands of books that he's
published on the different colors of
yarn the type of yarn the density of the
yarn the weave patterns of the yarns
and it does very very well
but
if for some reason they do an audit or
they go and drill down through
the uh audible store which is on acx
unit for example they don't like
something that you're doing with your
business they can actually hold back
your revenues and he's seen certain you
know scenarios where they've held back
revenues for a prolonged period of time
and he had to escalate and go through
all stuff and hire lawyers to get the
money out of it so running businesses on
somebody else's platform is
leading yourself into a half business
right hard annoyingly and frustrating
you have to be very very careful hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you